hi I'm Cate Blanchett and I play hella
in Marvel's Thor Ragnarok what would be
glad to see me
Marvel Studios Walt Disney Studios Dolby
Laboratories synchrony Bank and the
American Association for the Advancement
of science is seeking girls nationwide
just like you ages 15 to 18 currently
enrolled in grades 10 to 12 to channel
your superpower of stem science
technology engineering or math for good
by creating and then sharing an original
do-it-yourself project that could help
your family and your community make the
world a safer healthier happier place hi
I'm Mya duaa the winner of the Captain
America Civil War girls are forming the
future contest and I couldn't ask for a
better experience upon completion of the
contest five finalists will have been
selected and have the opportunity to
come to California for the red carpet
world premiere and one very talented and
lucky winner will be awarded the grand
prize hi there I'm ginger Zee the chief
meteorologist for ABC News and Good
Morning America as a female scientist I
am elated to tell you about the amazing
grand prize of Marvel Studios for
ragnaroks super power of stem challenge
the grand prize winner will have the
opportunity to attend an immersive
three-day mentorship in New York City
with Disney Imagineering and Disney
communication building their STEM story
creating a professional video teaching
other young people how to recreate their
winning project the grand prize winner
will then join me on TV to introduce
their video and to demonstrate their
superpower of stem project live to the
nation on GMA to top it all off the
video created by the winner during their
mentorship will become available
worldwide on the American Association
for the Advancement of science education
resource website science net links calm
to find out more about this exciting
challenge please visit Marvel Studios
STEM challenge that's all one word.com
[Music]